[Musique]
où
à
tous et bienvenue dont on n'est pas
sorti de l'auberge aujourd'hui on vous
emmène dans les hauts de l'ouest plus
précisément à la saline-les-hauts juste
sur les bords de la route hubert delisle
houde agnel est radin ouvert ici au beau
milieu des champs de canne une table
paysanne qui est une véritable
invitation à une escale culinaire vous
verrez faite de métissage et de touches
orientales alex partie
free n'a pas besoin père est temps
d'apprendre
il faut
on dit
bonjour madame bonjour bienvenue à la
ferme d'agly du mois il a dû chambre ton
petit bout de jardin perdu au milieu des
cannes à sucre oui
bienvenue à tabac glee haguenau d'accord
ok parce que moi j'avais lu annie j'ai
renoncé à glee mort de cette équipe est
venue dans la famille des personnes
avaient misé juste un an veniez de
l'inde
c'est un nom sacré
plus dur c'est l'effet c'est la lumière
parce qu'il faut bien dire que la
particularité de ta table paysanne c'est
quand même tourné vers la cuisine un peu
indienne et la ta spécialité qui est le
briani de brioni et c'est ce qui nous a
préparés pour ce midi briani végétal
végétal végétarien d'accord il adore
l'avion d'un c'est dommage et d'ici là
qu'est-ce qui me propose ben on va aller
dans les champs de canne on va couper de
quelque cannes à sucre pour faire des
réparations de vulcain d'accord je vais
m'en occuper si tu veux aller avant
d'être amené quelques
[Musique]
l'équipe
sait combien de superficie totale en
tout
c'est la comète déclare de cannes
[Musique]
rires on a pris encore
alors j'ai entendu dire qu'ils avaient
plusieurs variétés de cannes différentes
oui bah là bas chez nous on a planté
deux variétés
77 après il ya 86 586 583 il y en a
combien de variétés en tout eu ces infos
il ya plus beaucoup je ne sais pas je ne
sais pas ce que tu vois là cela c'est
bon quand c'est comme ça là et quand tu
dis qu'il ya plusieurs variétés à ce
qu'il a vraiment une différence au
niveau du goût oui tu as près d'effacer
dieu il ya des cannes c'est facile à
afficher ouais et après tout les
tonnages que ça allait encore avoir des
cales qui va être meilleur pour le jus
des canes qui vont peut-être meilleur
pour la pulpe en fonction de ce qu on a
planté là qu'elle te semble parfait pour
moi là celle-là
hockey
occupe toi encore un peu voilà prend de
la distance et la corde à 20
comment cela allait aller laisser aller
au bout
et après tu coupes
voilà à quoi je conduisais pas
partout là donc ça pour
voilà
bon jeu sera au moins deux coupeurs de
cannes
voilà un coup sec allez hop un seul coup
la
moins
attendue
après la swat et freddy au moins tu es à
ton âme
on vient de récupérer de la can je veux
me débarrasser de tout ça parce que je
suis pas vraiment fait pour ça
et puis on va passer à la préparation du
jus
[Musique]
allez je tendais si j'en prends us on
sera plus efficace à deux
pas du tout facile à travailler c'est il
faut allez venez d'abord été prise
partout pareil d'accord la turquie
affiche le câlin câline du coup à chaque
fois tu commences la promenade la
première technique c'est un dessin quoi
c'est super dur tu fais juste du jeu
avec en fait j en fais rang mar 11 et on
marche un peu aussi oui puis après on
peut le manger comme ça oui on peut
manger comme ça latchere que même pour
les randonnées ça que oui moi avant
j'avais l'habitude de khassan six mois
cette can et pendant que je marchais de
grignoter ça ça donne de la force de
noisy
du coup squale est de la technique exact
pour faire le jus
mais normalement moi j'aimais détruit
comme des mets de canne à sucre comme ça
comme ça et après je mets de citron qui
doit couper ça les noeuds alors tu vois
d'attention scripteur dois tu dois
couper l'aîné d'abord comme ça avec
justement qui a coupé des doigts
du coup maintenant qu'on a des petits
morceaux là de canne à sucre alors on
fait attention d'ailleurs parce que vous
avez vu la vitesse de couper le doigt on
fait quoi de ça ben on va fait on va
faire un jus de citron ouais et après un
classique dedans on va mettre un type et
quand la mode d'accord spectre sucre de
canne elle aussi ce week-end m tout ça
est fait et cannelle pourquoi filmer
tous d'accord alors c'est parti on met
ça deux ans déjà oui
peut-être un petit morceau de citron
moi je moi je touche plus au couteau
c'est fini au
citron et tuba danse comme ça on est
d'accord tu méchas directement en
tranches
tu vois c'est ça fait parfois c'est tout
petit peu de simplicité ça suffit enfin
médard ans et après on va mettre une
petite pincée de kandhamal ouais mais
l'effet qu'un éminent
on va mettez un fait qu'a réussi
jeudi
[Musique]
baptisé désolé tchin tchin et en fait
c'est ça c'est une citronnelle en fait
on dirait une citroën mais vraiment
c'est vrai que c'est très très bon c'est
super simple à faire mais c'est vraiment
très très bien
[Musique]
longtemps longtemps mais la route a fait
tony par hasard elle a trouvé
la tirah grisant de la misère
mais alors ce fameux briani comment dire
un peu plus parce que bon honnêtement
j'ai très rarement l'occasion d'en
manger et je suis content de venir chez
toi pour ça est ce que tu peux
m'expliquer un petit peu comment ça se
passe est-ce que tu mets dedans va
tester
du coup parce que là effectivement il a
été fait la veille non salavert on a
fait ce matin vers 5 heures parce que
leur île et brialy feu laisse reposer
ouais pour que ça que ça s'est passé
comment les bouviers grade tout les
arômes des dents ça a aidé cta souffl e
place à ccc odorants alors il ya quoi
donc on est amis on a préparé les pommes
de terre l'eau salée avec safran les riz
safrané
après on a mis haricots verts et
apprendre à fait cuisiner lé soja avec
les coriandre cumin lamente très
appétissant et ça c'est un plat qui
marche vraiment bien c'est à dire que
c'est celui-là tu voulais que tu
proposes le plus apte à table paysanne
ces cellules à quai les clients
cherchent tu proposes la cuisine
indienne indienne et tu propose aussi la
cuisine créole c'est à dire qu'elles ces
gens venir et manger un bon vieux
rougail saucisses on est d'accord pour
le faire ou à ceux ci s'en fait cavani
en fait poulets au sens je voulais c'est
super joli c'est très visuel et tout se
passe au feu de bois et ses hauts faits
de bois bon allez on va l'allumer
celui-là oui allez tu ton charge
d'allègements en charge et mon chat je
me suis déjà coupé un doigt si je dois
me wade je préfère que ce soit moi
ça y est le briane est en train de
chauffer donc ici j'imagine que c'est là
que ta qualité client
oui ici et des dents aussi mais là
aujourd'hui c'est me dit on va faire ici
et puis on peut profiter de la vue qui
est quand même assez assez époustouflant
ce tube à coeur comme client et 25 sur
réservation sur réservation oui hélas
aujourd'hui on va manger sur les
feuilles banane oui ça fait près de
tokyo laissant de fait peu de temps
je vois que trois couverts est quelqu'un
qui mélange membres oui mon mari daniel
oui et ceux qui peuvent plus du côté de
la musique et l'ambiance il met
l'ambiance québécois passant de
rencontrer
bonjour daniel bonjour enchanté moi je
vais attendre que tu te liberia me les
mains
[Musique]
comment ça va bien si je n'avais délit
madame fait à manger et toi tu amènes
les plats et l'animation et l'animation
oui c'est vrai que j'ai vu des guitares
à prendre toutes les disperser dans la
maison n'est pas qu'une seule oui
c'est quoi céder c'est pourquoi vous
proposer des prestations musicales à
chaque enchère mais ce sens qu'il ya des
clients si on n'est pas trop nombreux
sens et tous les deux si on est nombreux
si l'occasion se présente il ya c'est
que guitariste c'est un petit peu à 20
heures perdues bah ouais tu penses qu'on
pouvait se faire un petit buzz après
manger on verra bien
en tout cas il est magnifique c'est
yannick et donc du coup après il ya le
rail tard
le right right à ces
concombres carottes yaourt lula lui
rajoute un score plus ce à quoi j'ai
attrapé alors je vais prendre un risque
qu'un seul nom sera augmentée non mais
c'est une sonorité c'est aussi indiens
oui parce si rapidement oui
[Musique]
l'attaqué
donc après ce magnifique ce délicieux
briani on passe au dessert et là c'est
pareil on reste toujours dans la culture
culinaire indienne voilà alors qu'est ce
qu'on a avec des bonbons au miel comme
cech façon napolitaine avec moyens
napolitaine
et aussi à côté fait un petit cadeau aux
amis
[Musique]
que non les leurs
seulement comment de l'arrivée ça ne
connaît pas
des migrants la transformer
nana qui dit adam
voyez pas
comment
oh ça va
aurons-nous l'arrivée ça ne collait pas
[Musique]
et tu joues que pour tes clients oui et
plus bas des temps oui sinon je les
églises mais on a tous joué chez nous et
tu faisais pas ça professionnels en la
musique non non tu sais quoi elle évoque
un bon d'avoir ouvert sept tableaux
paysans on n'est ni domaine des milliers
comme ça un commerce bar salle de jeu je
crois que tu ris donc il ya les clients
on a l'habitude ouais donc au final
c'est ce serait presque imposé à toi
finalement nouveau la table paysanne pas
prédestiné oui il ya combien de temps ce
le comminges ça fait 25 ans dans la
couverture de table le paysage
cinquante cinq ans à peu près dans ce
qui concerne ta femme rada faisait
courir c'était plus de respect de
l'éducation cor anglais et un mail en
langues orientales parle beaucoup de
confort qui va être longue c'est bien
mais ça va plus aussi pour l'aspect
touristique ou plus recevoir des gens
aisés monde entier et quasiment sans
aucun problème et pour les prochaines
années la tad et à des projets ici oui
des chambres des gens mais britney
l'atelier de cuisine et si moi j'ai
envie d'aller faire un petit tour là
dans l'heure qui me conseillent quel
endroit très très basse et la forêt
trois bassins et on est à 15 minutes la
même pas c'est quoi ça c'est le tu me
parles de la route forestière notamment
oui d'accord ok pense que je vais y
aller je vais acheter un à donner je
vais les prendre l'air je te remercie
beaucoup je te remercie pour toutes ces
découvertes aujourd'hui tu feras un gros
bisou à ta femme de ma part et moi je
trouve à
aller très très vite
[Musique]
sous les conseils de daniel à combien tu
as mené cette mission ici sur leur faut
rester indépendant alors vous l'aurez
compris si vous cherchez à découvrir la
culture culinaire indienne a passé un
bon moment aux musiques en compagnie des
gens aussi chaleureux et accueillant je
vous donne à dresser la table paysanne
haguenau et ça se passe à la
saline-les-hauts en ce qui nous concerne
on se retrouve très très vite sur les
routes de la réunion
[Musique]